here's a scary thought what if we can't
stop climate change most of the talk
about climate change has been about
reducing the emissions we're going to
make but what about the emissions we've
already made so if we cut all emissions
to zero tomorrow it could be that the
world still warms up quite a lot over
this century because of what are called
carbon feedbacks since the beginning of
the Industrial Revolution we've already
added 531 billion tons of carbon
emissions to the atmosphere that has led
to a roughly one and a half degree rise
in average global surface temperatures
so far which in turn is causing ice caps
to melt sea levels to rise and has been
linked to extreme droughts and storms we
need to have technologies which allow us
to have a high standard of living while
being in carbon balances and we have
done it with clean air in this country
and I think we can also do it with
stopping climate change cleaning up our
existing nests is going to be hard
expensive and controversial but it's
also going to be necessary fortunately
some people are already figuring out how
we'll do it
Klaus Lackner and his colleagues want us
to rethink our relationship with carbon
dioxide here at Arizona State
University's Center for negative carbon
emissions they see it as a waste
management problem this is like sewage
this is like garbage and you cannot just
dump it in the atmosphere and I'll give
you an example if I were to dump my
garbage in the street in front of my
house got my neighborhood you would
object and you wouldn't think it was all
that cool on my part to come back to you
the next day and say I internally
improved my efficiencies and I'm happy
to announce that I'm only dumping 80% of
what I used to dump into the street you
would say clean up that mess and get rid
of it right now
technologies already exist to capture
co2 at large emitters like the
smokestacks of power plants but for the
co2 already in our atmosphere Lackner is
working on a technology to actually suck
co2 out of the sky
he started his research by looking at a
device that already does this pretty
well in a way it all started with trees
right the question is can you pull co2
out of the atmosphere and you look at a
tree and the answer is yes you can he
wants to make a synthetic version that
works even better certainly you can pull
up plow over the horse but you're better
off getting a tractor
this is his tractor Lackner steam has
been working on different versions of
this technology for more than a decade
the key component is this papery
material which is embedded with a resin
that can absorb carbon dioxide from the
air our take on this material and our
twist and our discovery is that it also
has a strong affinity for carbon dioxide
especially when it's in a dry state now
I have sort of a spoon I can grab the
co2 of it crucially the material also
lets go of co2 dunk it in water or
expose it to high humidity and it
releases the carbon dioxide for
collection it can be pumped underground
fed to greenhouses or to algae for
biofuel or perhaps in the future even
used to make carbon-based materials once
the co2 is gone you can dry the membrane
in the air and reuse it Lackner expects
the material will work for thousands of
cycles this particular piece of material
is probably 10 years old and it's
working just fine
right now the lab is working on
different designs to maximize the
materials contact with air so this was
just the material run through a pasta
maker kind of thing that rug in there
was literally woven by some poor
undergrads this was a bit of a reality
check to see if in fact this accordion
idea would work and in fact it does
black nurse data suggests the material
soundly beats nature and capturing
carbon from the atmosphere you have an
object the size of this tree made out of
our material we roughly collect a
thousand times as much co2 we in a given
amount of time to suck up the amount of
co2 humans are currently emitting would
require a massive number of synthetic
trees and that's the scale of cleanup
Lackner is interested in this is the
mock-up Lackner and his colleagues
created to show what their device would
look like if implemented on a large
scale and fits into a standard shipping
container and if you wanted to balance
current emissions you would need a
hundred million containers that's not a
small footprint it's not a quick fix and
the technology isn't cheap but neither
were solar panels and windmills when
they were first developed on an
optimistic note when I started this in
1995 people just thought is crazy even
to work on it and that that has changed
dramatically
critics of this technology argued that
the ability to scrub co2 from the
atmosphere might weaken our will to stop
using fossil fuels but the damage has
already been done and it needs fixing
sooner rather than later we have done it
on ozone we have done it on rivers yeah
we have the same thing and it's only a
question of how much does it have to
hurt before we make this step the danger
is by the time it hurts it's too late
blocking out the Sun sounds like the
plot of a Bond villain but for David
Keith a physicist at Harvard University
it's not a plot to destroy the planet
it's about to save it Keith is
researching solar geoengineering that's
the proposal to spray tiny reflective
particles into the upper atmosphere
bouncing sunlight back into space and
lowering global temperatures this
technology might be able to quickly cool
the earth if things get devastatingly
humped I don't think we know enough now
to say that we should do it I think in
fact it would be lunacy to argue that we
should start right now but what I do
think is there's enough evidence that it
could have enormous benefits benefits in
many cases to the poorest and most
vulnerable the old the world will be
most affected by climate change that we
ought to have a serious research program
but we don't China does and there are
some research programs in Europe but in
America just advocating for
geoengineering research is very
controversial the kind of official u.s.
position is ignorance which is really
disturbing people on the side of the
community will say it's reckless to
research this or talk about it because
it will weaken the political force to
cut emissions and I think that really
misconceives the job of science if we
actually think these technologies can
reduce risks it's our duty to say so
obviously it's impossible to get
approval in the u.s. to inject particles
into the stratosphere to measure what
happens so keeps lab is built a tiny
atmosphere of its bone for testing
specifically the glass tube that you see
in here is a simulation of the
stratosphere we can simulate these very
cold temperatures in the stratosphere we
can also put UV lamps around this that
simulate the sunlight conditions in the
stratosphere the goal is to find
materials that can effectively reflect
light while not damaging the atmosphere
we will look at Diamond dust as one of
the potential candidates yes it is the
diamonds in the sky experiment the leap
from lab experiment to deploying this
worldwide is a large one and that's not
lost on Keith no amount of research on
this technology will remove the
uncertainties the fact is we've put now
for a hundred years an enormous amount
of co2 in the atmosphere and we still
don't know the climate's response to co2
accurate because the climate is a noisy
beast if we engineering the Earth's
atmosphere sounds a bit extreme to you
you're not alone even though we
accidentally messed up the climate some
feel fixing it by deliberately
manipulating the climate could have
unknown consequences ones worse than our
current problem it's a deep question why
people seem to be more concerned about
deliberate tinkering that actually aims
to reduce environmental risks then they
are about all sorts of hideous ways we
damage the environment Solar
geoengineering would work quickly and
cheaply but it's not a permanent
solution it addresses the symptoms of
climate change not the causes but if our
efforts to cut carbon emissions don't
work fast enough it may be our only
option I think it's very fair to think
of this as a bad date or a kludge but
band-aids aren't a bad thing if you're
wounded you want band-aids it's
something that is imperfect that doesn't
deal with a root cause but might
substantially reduce the risks
you